bonjour à tous alors ça fait plusieurs
fois que je les boks sur la chaîne mais
je n'avais jamais eu l'occasion de faire
une vidéo spécifique dessus aujourd'hui
on va parler de la mécanique quantique à
la mécanique quantique qu'est ce que
c'est et ben c'est la meilleure théorie
dont on dispose à l'heure actuelle pour
comprendre et expliquer le comportement
de la matière au niveau microscopique
microscopique ça veut dire les atomes et
puis tout ce qu'il ya de plus petits que
les atomes et notamment toutes les
particules comme les protons dont les
électrons les photons et c'est donc
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous présenter
cette grande idée qui sont vraiment au
coeur de la mécanique quantique et donc
vous allez voir quelles sont toutes
fortement contre intuitive elle nous
montre que le monde au niveau
microscopique fonctionne d'une manière
bien différente de ceux dont on a
l'habitude
à notre échelle
la première idée c'est la plus
importante parce que c'est celle dont
tout découle
c'est peut-être aussi la plus choquante
on l'appelle le principe de
superposition
alors pour comprendre ce que c'est on va
commencer par considérer des objets qui
sont macroscopique alors par exemple une
balle de tennis ou bien la lune ou bien
même un grain de sable qui voltigent
dans tous ces objets ils sont trop gros
pour obéir aux lois de la mécanique
quantique
on dit que ce sont des objets classiques
si vous considérez un objet classiques
comme par exemple une balle de tennis un
instant donné
bon bah elle a une certaine vitesse et
puis elle se trouve dans une certaine
position de l'espace on dit qu'elle est
dans un état bien défini eh bien ça au
niveau quantique ça n'est plus vrai
c'est à dire que les objets quantique
ils peuvent être dans plusieurs états à
la fois ça veut dire par exemple qu'un
électron peut être à la fois ici et là
ou bien aller en même temps à mille
kilomètres par seconde et à deux mille
kilomètres par seconde un électron il
peut être dans deux états à la fois
c'est bizarre non
mais bon va falloir vous y habituer
parce que dans le monde quantique ça se
passe comme ça
les objets peuvent être dans plusieurs
états à la fois ils peuvent être dans
plusieurs états superposés et c'est pour
ça qu'on appelle ça le principe de
superposition
alors pour faire face à cette
possibilité un petit peu bizarre les
physiciens ont été obligés d'inventer
une notation particulière on va décrire
chaque état entre une barre et un
crochet comme ça et donc par exemple
pour dire que l'électron va simplement à
mille kilomètres par seconde
on écrit ça et quand un objet et dans
plusieurs états à la fois eh ben on
ajoute les états ont les superpose et
donc par exemple pour dire qu'un
électron va à la fois à 1000 et à deux
mille kilomètres par seconde
on écrit ça dans cette histoire on n'est
pas du tout obligé de se limiter à
superposer deux états ont peu en
superposés 3 4 5 et même une infinité un
exemple très classique c'est que quand
un électron tourne autour d'un proton
dans l'atome d'hydrogène et ben il est
sur tous les points de son orbite à la
fois évidemment vous voyez à quel point
ça contraste avec ceux dont on a
l'habitude au niveau macroscopique 1 par
exemple la lune en ce moment eh ben elle
est sur un point de son orbite à l'est
pas sur tous les points en même temps
heureusement pour nous toutes ces
superpositions bizarre elle n'existe
qu'au niveau microscopique elle n'arrive
jamais à notre échelle et d'ailleurs
c'était pour voir jusqu'où on pouvait
pousser le concept que schrödinger avait
imaginé son expérience de pensée du chat
vous savez le chat qui serait à la fois
mort et vivant
maintenant que je vous expliquais l'idée
centrale de la mécanique quantique qui
est celle du principe de superposition
je vais pouvoir en dérouler toutes les
conséquences bizarre qui en découle est
la première concerne ce qui se passe
quand on essaye de mesurer les objet
quantique
prenons d'abord un objet classique une
balle de tennis bon bah si je la lance
je peux essayer de mesurer sa vitesse
par exemple en utilisant des espèces de
radars qu'on trouve parfois sur les
courts de tennis dans les tournois un en
prenons notre électrons qui va à la fois
à mille kilomètres par seconde et à deux
mille kilomètres par seconde
et imaginons ce qui se passe si on le
fait passer dans une sorte de radar à
électrons si on fait ça à votre avis et
qu'on essaie de mesurer sa vitesse
qu'est ce qu'on va trouver
est ce qu'on va trouver mille est ce
qu'on va trouver 2000 est ce qu'on va
trouver la moyenne des 2500 et bien en
fait rien de tout ça exactement
on va avoir une chance sur deux de
trouver mille et une chance sur deux de
trouver 2000 en mécanique quantique
quand on a des états superposés et bien
les résultats des mesures dépendent en
partie du hasard on dit qu'il ya un an
un déterminisme
c'est à dire que si je refais 100 fois
la même expérience avec un électron
exactement dans le même état eh ben je
vais trouver mille une cinquantaine de
fois et puis je vais trouver 2000 une
cinquantaine de fois cette situation
elle est évidemment totalement
différente de ce qui se passe avec les
objets normaux comme les balles de
tennis si vous mesurez 100 fois la même
balle de tennis lancé exactement la même
manière vous allez trouver cent fois à
peu près la même réponse
vous allez pas trouvé des choses très
différentes comme ce qu'on pourrait
avoir avec les électrons ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que ce hasard quantique
il est vraiment intrinsèque fondamental
c'est par exemple assez différent de ce
qui se passe quand on tire à pile ou
face parce qu'on pourrait dire bah oui
quand on tire à pile ou face séparé il
ya un un déterminisme
on ne sait pas à l'avancé si on va
trouver pile ou face et on a une chance
sur deux de retrouver l'un et l'autre
mais la différence c'est que si vous
tirez cent fois de suite à pile ou face
exactement la même manière en lançant la
pièce exactement la même manière et bien
vous allez trouver cent fois le même
résultat
et même si vous connaissez exactement la
position la pièce sa rotation sa vitesse
etc
vous pouvez au moins en principe prêt
dire sur quel côté elle va tomber
vassa en mécanique quantique c'est pas
possible il n'y a aucun moyen de savoir
à l'avancé quel va être le résultat de
la mesure
vous avez peut-être que cette idée de
hasard quantique elle choqué beaucoup
einstein qui était pas du tout d'accord
avec ça et qui un jour avait lancé à
nice
or dieu ne joue pas aux dés ce à quoi
bord lui avait malicieusement répondu
mais qui êtes vous pour dire adieu ce
qu'il doit faire
là il répond rien j'ai cassé j'ai gagné
dans l'exemple que je vous ai donné avec
mes vitesses d'électrons on avait des
probabilités de 50 50 mais en fait c'est
pas obligé que ce soit toujours 50 50
parce qu'à une chose que je vous ai pas
dit c'est que quand on s'amuse à
superposer des états on peut le faire
avec des proportions un peu comme dans
un cocktail dont on pourra imaginer un
électron qui soit pour un dixième à
mille kilomètres par seconde et pour
neuf dixièmes à deux mille kilomètres
par seconde
donc si vous avez un électron qui est
dans cet état superposé et ben si vous
essayez de mesurer sa vitesse vous allez
trouver deux mille kilomètres par
seconde dans 90 % des cas et mille
kilomètres par seconde dans 10% des cas
depuis le début je vous ai pris
l'exemple de la vitesse d'un électron
mais il faut bien voir que ça c'est vrai
pour toutes les propriétés des
particules au niveau quantique c'est à
dire que ça pourrait aussi se produire
si on essayait de mesurer la position
l'énergie ou le spin d'une particule en
mécanique quantique c'est intrinsèques
les résultats des mesures dépendent
toujours en partie du hasard
continuons avec les conséquences un peu
étrange du principe de superposition sur
la mesure
alors on va reprendre notre électrons
qui va à la fois à 1000 et à deux mille
kilomètres par seconde
on imagine qu'on fait passer dans un
radar et imaginons qu'on trouve mille
bon ben maintenant supposer que juste
derrière je refasse passé cet électron
dans un deuxième radar à votre avis
qu'est ce que je vais trouver
est ce que je vais trouver à nouveau
1000 ou 2000 a une chance sur deux et
ben non en fait je vais trouver
exactement la même chose que ce que
j'avais dans la première mesure si
j'avais trouvé mille j'ai toujours
trouvé mille si j'avais trouvé 2000 j'ai
toujours trouvé de mieux à la deuxième
mesure il n'y a plus d'un déterminisme
c'est comme si la première mesure avait
forcé l'électron à choisir son camp et à
décider à quelle vitesse ils allaient
vraiment la manière dont on l'interprète
c'est qu'on dit qu'avant la première
mesure l'électron est dans son état
superposé 1 1000 et 2000 et que la
première mesure le force à aller dans
l'état qui correspond à ce qu'on va
mesurer donc dans ce cas là il sera
ensuite uniquement dans les tamils et
donc ensuite quand on essaye de leur
mesure et avec un deuxième radar et ben
on trouvera 1000 à tous les coups on dit
que l'électron n'est plus dans un état
superposé on dit que son état a été
projeté ou réduits ce qui est bizarre
dans cette histoire c'est que le fait de
mesurer la vitesse de l'électron a en
fait considérablement affecté son état
et c'est quelque chose de très générales
en mécanique quantique on peut pas
mesurer les états d objet quantique sans
les perturber
fondamentalement c'est évidemment très
différent de ce qu'on a avec notre balle
de tennis puisque quand je mesure la
vitesse d'une balle de tennis avec un
radar j'affecte pas tellement la vitesse
de la balle de tennis je vais pas
perturber sa trajectoire ni rien du coup
l'idée suivante c'est une des plus
connues et vous allez voir qu'elle
découle aussi naturellement du principe
de superposition
donc on a dit qu'on avait la possibilité
de superposer deux trois quatre et même
une infinité d'état et on a dit qu'on
pouvait aussi les superposer en faisant
varier les proportions
imaginons un électron qui pour faire
simple va en ligne droite
et puis on va dire que cet électron il
est à la fois là là et là et puis on
peut s'amuser à faire varier les
proportions donc on peut dire qu'il est
un petit peu plus au centre que sur les
côtés bon ben on peut pousser le concept
plus loin et considérer un électron qui
serait un petit peu partout à la fois et
donc on peut s'amuser à tracer une
courbe sur cette ligne qui représentent
la proportion de trouver l'électron à
sandro là donc on peut imaginer par
exemple une courbe qui décrirait un
électron qui serait un petit peu ici
puis pas du tout là puis à nouveau
beaucoup ici pas du tout là et puis un
petit peu là cette courbe on l'appelle
la probabilité de présence parce qu'elle
décrit la probabilité de trouver
l'électron sur chacun des endroits de
notre ligne alors ça c'était pour un
instant donné
maintenant on peut imaginer que quand le
temps s'écoule cette probabilité elle va
changer elle va bouger
et donc là vous voyez que ce qu'on a
sous les yeux commence à se comporter
pas mal comme une onde qui se propage
une onde de probabilités et vous voyez
sur cet exemple que une particule qu'au
départ on avait envie de décrire comme
un objet ponctuelles finalement on se
retrouve à les décrire plus tôt par une
onde et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve tout le temps en mécanique
quantique et qu'on appelle la dualité on
corpuscules le fait que les objets
ponctuelle ou qu'on croit ponctuelles se
comporte en fait au niveau microscopique
comme des ondes à cette idée elle
devrait pas vous êtes totalement
étrangère puisque on sait notamment que
c'est ce qui se passe pour la lumière la
lumière suivant les circonstances elle
se comporte comme une particules le
photon ou bien comme une onde l'ondé
électromagnétique le fait que les
particules de matière se comportent
comme des ondes a plein de conséquences
assez amusant kline que j'aime bien
c'est que quand une particule a l'air de
se déplacer d'un point à un autre
en fait elle fait le déplacement en
empruntant à la fois tous les chemins
possibles par exemple si vous imaginez
balancer des balles de tennis sur un mur
dans lequel il y aurait deux fenêtres
ouvertes vont vous
allez avoir un certain nombre de balles
qui vont toucher le mur et puis vous
allez avoir des balles qui vont passer
par la première fenêtre et des balles
qui vont passer par la deuxième fenêtre
maintenant si vous refaites l'expérience
avec des électrons alors on peut
utiliser un canon électrons à ça existe
et que vous balancez des électrons sur
un écran sur lequel vous avez percé de
trous et ben on peut montrer que si un
électron passent par l'un des trous en
fait ils passent aussi un petit peu par
l'autre trou c'est à dire que l'électron
il emprunte à la fois tous les chemins
possibles
alors ça c'est une expérience qui est
vraiment très très intrigante et donc il
faudra que je vous reparle un jour parce
que c'est peut-être une des expériences
les plus spectaculaires et les plus
importantes de la physique du 20e siècle
il ya une autre conséquence très bizarre
du comportement ondulatoire de la
matière au niveau microscopique c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'effet tunnel
alors reprenons nos balles de tennis
qu'on balance et imaginons qu on les
balance cette fois contre un mur sur
lequel n'y a pas de fenêtre
bon bah si je balance une balle elle va
rebondir et sigean balance dix ans un
million et ben elles vont toutes
rebondir à votre avis qu'est ce qui se
passe si on fait ça avec des électrons
il faut se souvenir que un électron au
niveau microscopique
il est décrit par une onde qu'est ce qui
se passe quand je balance une onde
contre un obstacle
vous pouvez penser par exemple aux ondes
sonores imaginez vous êtes chez vous
vous écoutez de la musique un peu fort
si vous avez un mur qui vous sépare de
chez le voisin londres sonore qui arrive
sur le mur qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
belle va être en partie absorbée en
partie réfléchi et puis il y en a
toujours une toute petite partie qui va
traverser le mur qui va être transmise
et donc votre voisin va entendre votre
musique
bon ben maintenant si on transpose ça au
cas de l'undd qui décrit un électron
qu'on va balancer contre un obstacle
ça veut dire qu'il ya une toute petite
partie de l'ong de probabilité qui va
être transmise de l'autre côté et donc
ça veut dire que il y a une petite
probabilité que l'électron se retrouve
de l'autre côté de l'obstacle
cette probabilité elle est généralement
faibles mais ça veut dire que si vous
balancer un grand nombre d'électrons
contrat l'obstacle est bien de temps en
temps tout se passe comme si pour l'un
de ces électrons il y avait un petit
tunnel qui s'ouvrait dans le mur et le
laisser passer
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça
l'effet tunnel alors l'effet tunnel
c'est par exemple lui qui permet de
comprendre le phénomène de radioactivité
la radioactivité c'est le fait qu'un
noyau atomique peut se désintégrer en
émettant généralement des particules et
bien les missions de cette particule on
peut la voir comme résultant de l'effet
tunnel pour comprendre ça il faut
imaginer qu'un noyau atomique c'est tout
un tas de protons et de neutrons en tas
qui sont maintenus entre eux parce qu'on
appelle la force nucléaire forte
vous imaginez que c'est un peu comme
s'il était dans une pièce et qu'ils
étaient confinés entre eux comme ça et
puis ils sont très agités
et de temps en temps sous l'effet du
hasard il ya un petit groupe de
particules qui peut arriver à s'échapper
en franchissant la barrière par effet
tunnel et donc ça provoque l'émission
d'une particule et c'est ça qu'on
appelle la radioactivité il faut savoir
que l'effet tunnel à d'autres
applications concrètes et il y en a une
qui est assez joli c'est ce qu'on
appelle le microscope à effet tunnel
le microscope à effet tunnel c'est le
premier microscope qui a permis dans les
années 80 je crois devoir pour la
première fois les atomes
voyez surtout les exemples que j'ai
données que du fait de leur comportement
ondulatoire les particules quantiques
elle peut faire tout un tas de trucs
vachement sympa que les particules
classiques ne peuvent pas faire elles
peuvent être à plusieurs endroits à la
fois elles peuvent passer par tous les
chemins en même temps et peut même
traverser les murs donc ça laisse quand
même vachement cool d'être une particule
quantique
sauf que là on va voir une restriction
qu'elles ont quand même c'est que
certaines de leurs propriétés sont
quantifiés oui parce que à ce stade vous
vous demandez peut-être pourquoi la
mécanique quantique s'appelle la
mécanique quantique
d'ailleurs une certaine époque on
l'appelait plutôt la mécanique
ondulatoire elles étant donné ce qu'on
vient de voir ce n'est pas forcément une
mauvaise idée
alors pour comprendre pourquoi la
mécanique quantique des quantiques
on va retourner à nouveau à l'exemple
d'un objet classique on va considérer
par exemple un satellite en orbite
autour de la terre vont donc il est sur
une certaine orbite on peut mesurer le
rayon entre le centre de la terre et l
orbite du satellite et à partir de ça on
peut calculer tout un tas de choses sur
sa trajectoire et on peut notamment
calculé son énergie il ya une formule
pour ça donc là j'ai placé mon satellite
à une certaine orbite et donc il a une
certaine énergie mais j'aurais très bien
pu le mettre sur une orbite qui était
juste un pouillème plus haute ou juste
un pouillème plus basse et si j'avais
fait ça et bien son énergie elle aurait
été juste un pouillème plus élevé ou
juste un pouillème préceptes mais il n'y
a pas d'énergie interdite où il n'ya pas
d'orbites interdite versa au niveau
microscopique ça ne marche le plus par
exemple un électron qui tourne autour
d'un proton il peut pas avoir n'importe
quelle énergie
en fait il ya même que quelques valeurs
d'énergie qui sont possibles alors une
manière de l'interpréter c'est de dire
que c'est comme si l'électron n'avait
que certaines orbite possible et que ça
lui fait absolument interdit d'aller sur
les orbites intermédiaire donc du coup
ses orbites ou plutôt ces niveaux
d'énergie
on leur donne des numéros 1 2 3 4 et
donc le niveau d'énergie le plus faible
c'est le numéro un c'est à dire que
c'est impossible d'avoir une énergie qui
soit plus faible que ça et ça veut dire
une certaine manière que c'est
impossible pour l'électron d'aller sur
une orbite qui soit encore plus proche
du proton et ça c'est l'illustration du
fait que pour un électron qui tourne
autour d'un proton l'énergie et
quantifier c'est à dire qu'elle ne peut
prendre que certaines valeurs possibles
qui évidemment différent de ce qu'on a
généralement en mécanique classique
où a priori toutes les énergies sont
possibles on peut prendre une énergie de
n'importe quelle valeur à ce phénomène
de quantification on peut le trouver un
petit peu bizarre mais vous allez voir
c'est finalement une conséquence assez
naturel du fait qu' on traite les
particules au niveau quantique comme des
ondes
alors pour comprendre ça vous pouvez
penser aux ondulations d'une corde de
guitare une corde de guitare si elle est
bien attaché à ses deux extrémités
elle ne peut vibrer que de certaines
manières alors la manière la plus simple
c'est celle ci on appelle sable
fondamentale dont ça correspond à la
fréquence la plus grave possible mais
elle peut aussi vibrer de cette manière
là ils correspondent à une fréquence de
deux fois plus élevé ou celle ci nous
formuler bc terme donc pour la corde de
guitare vous voyez qu'il n'ya que
certaine fréquence de vibration qui sont
permises et c'est absolument impossible
de la faire vivre et à des fréquences
qui serait intermédiaire on peut dire
que les vibrations de la corde de
guitare sont quantifiés et ben c'est à
peu près pour la même raison que les
niveaux d'énergie de l'atome d'hydrogène
sont quantifiées eux aussi
la dernière idée qu'on va voir c'est une
des plus connues mais c'est aussi une
des plus insaisissable c'est ce qu'on
appelle le principe d'incertitude de
heisenberg alors tout à l'heure je vous
ai expliqué qu'on pouvait décrire les
objets quantique par des états et on
peut avoir des états très simples comme
par exemple la vitesse est égal à mille
kilomètres par seconde
bien la position est égal à 40 2 comme
un objet classique il est généralement
décrit à la fois par sa vitesse et sa
position on pourrait se demander s'il
était possible de fabriquer un état
quantique qui soit à la fois une vitesse
et une position donnée par exemple x
égale 42 et vega le mil et ben non ça
c'est pas possible à cause du principe
d'incertitude d'heisenberg qui nous dit
que en mécanique quantique
on peut pas avoir un état qui décrivent
une particule dont la position et la
vitesse sont toutes les deux
parfaitement définis et même plus vous
êtes précis sur la définition de la
vitesse
- vous pouvez l'être sur celle de la
position en gros plus on sait à quelle
vitesse elle va et moins on sait où elle
est et réciproquement
l'exemple extrême c'est celui par
exemple d'un électron qui iraient
simplement à mille kilomètres par
seconde comme on le supposait tout à
l'heure et bien cet électron ça veut
dire qu'il peut se trouver à peu près
n'importe où dans l'espace alors ce
principe d'incertitude d'heisenberg il
peut sembler complètement
incompréhensible mais on peut le
percevoir en se référant à nouveau aux
ondes sonores
donc vous savez que le son est composé
de fréquences et quand vous enregistrer
un signal sonore comme celui ci
vous voyez généralement l'intensité du
son en fonction du temps mais on peut
aussi s'amuser à regarder sa
décomposition en fréquence on peut
utiliser par exemple un logiciel de
traitement du son est donc là on peut
repérer les fréquences du dos du sol et
de leurs harmonique qui corresponde aux
notes que j'ai joué dans l'accord est
une chose que vous pouvez observer si
vous jouez avec ses différentes des
compositions c'est que plus un son et
bref plus il va contenir deux fréquences
par exemple sont percussions sera très
très court dans le temps mais il sera
très étalée en fréquence et inversement
si vous voulez un son qui soit très plus
on veut mais quand c'est à dire qu'ils
ne contiennent qu'une fréquence ou
presque se sont devra nécessairement
être suffisamment long on peut pas avoir
à la fois un son qui serait très court
dans le temps et très pur en fréquence
la raison c'est que la durée et la
fréquence d'un son sont deux choses qui
sont irrémédiablement liés
eh bien il se passe exactement la même
chose avec la vitesse et la position des
particules qu'on décrit comme des ondes
de probabilités comme la position et la
vitesse sont un peu les deux facettes de
la même réalité on peut pas spécifié à
la fois parfaitement la position et la
vitesse de la même manière qu'on peut
pas avoir un son qui soit à la fois
parfaitement localisés dans le temps et
parfaitement localisés en fréquence mon
cul si tout ça vous paraît trop
compliqué vous pouvez retenir que le
principe d'incertitude de heisenberg
c'est quand même essentiellement alors
je sais que j'ai garé la voiture mais je
sais que nous voilà c'était les sept
idées les plus importantes de la
mécanique quantique alors pour finir
quand même une remarque qui peut
paraître évidente mais qui mérite d'être
fait ce que je viens de vous raconter là
c'est pas un cours de mécanique
quantique 1 ce n'est pas du tout parlé
du formalisme j'ai pas parlé des
équations mais tout ça c'est juste de la
vulgarisation
donc ça veut dire que j'ai été obligé de
prendre des analogies qui sont parfois
un peu foireuse j'ai été obligé de dire
des choses imprécise voir deux fois des
choses qui sont carrément fausses si
vous voulez en savoir plus j'ai écrit un
petit billet sur mon blog qui précisent
pas mal de choses que j'ai racontée ici
et je mettrai le lien quelque part voilà
merci d'avoir suivi cette longue vidéo
si elle vous a plu surtout n'hésitez pas
à la partager
monde entier vous pouvez bien sûr vous
abonner à la chaîne s'est pas déjà fait
vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook twitter
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me
soutenir sertic et puis vous pouvez
aussi vous retrouver sur mon blog cette
alliance étonnante merci et à bientôt